What's the value of a stool test?
I thought I recall you say our guy microbiome changes so quickly in response to what you
eat.
It doesn't really give you valuable info.
Well, there's different stool tests that are out there.
The most common stool test is a gut microbiome test that you're talking about, but more common
than that would be a gut microbiome test that is testing for pathogens, so it's testing
for parasites.
Now, that can be a valuable test if you have serious gut issues that you just can't
seem to get into balance.
Now, even when I was taking care of more people with just functional medicine issues, that's
not a test that I did on a regular basis, because to me, first of all, yes, you could
have parasites that do cause ill health, but in truth, there's parasites that can't actually
even be beneficial.
That effect, one treatment seems really weird, but a treatment for autoimmune disease can
actually be giving you a person different types of parasites, because when you have different
parasites living symbiotically, in that case, in you, it can actually help comb down a hyper
immune response that many people have with TH1 dominant autoimmune conditions.
It's not about, I know a lot of functional medicine doctors that are able to do a parasite
test all the time, and they're all into, we got to kill every parasite in your gut.
That's just, you look throughout the animal kingdom, that's just, that's just not always
the case.
I mean, animals live symbiotically, parasitically, sometimes, and can actually help that work,
the organism that is being found, but it's not that all pathogens or parasites are good
for us.
But certainly not all of them need to be killed and need to be searched out in hunting either.
So I think it's better on getting the gut back in order from an inflammatory standpoint,
maybe looking at things that are causing, you know, gut damage and epithelial damage, which
was most commonly not parasites, it's much more commonly food sensitivities and toxins
that have damage to epithelial air, and you've got to heal the epithelial air and get rid
of anything that's causing a fire every time you, let's say if you have antibodies to gluten
and you're eating gluten every day, well, you're causing this giant fire and you're gut every
day.
There's no way, okay, how much gut healing products that you're going to take, you're never
going to heal the gut if you're causing inflammatory damage on it, you know, every time you eat
a meal.
So running a Cyrex panel, three X or four Ray, three X or a four or a Ray 10 could be highly
valuable to find out if you are, if that's the case, and then, and then dealing with that
so that you can work concurrently to heal the gut.
And remember, we talked about this multiple times in the last six months or so.
It's a place that you start with healing, the gut is stomach and the HCl and the stomach
because that's your, that's your number one cause for damage in the gut, and it's your
number one cause of the reason why a person would get pathological organisms from the food
they eat, because, you know, if I eat sushi that has worms in it, then our microscopic
and I can't see it or worms, if I am healthy, HCl and the gut, you know, 99% of them will
be killed off by the HCl and my gut and the rest will be destroyed by the enzymes in my
duodenum.
But here's the problem number one is people don't have enough HCl in their stomach, that's
why I suggest taking an HCl supplement with each meal, something like clear digester, HCl
cells or something like that, because you will kill that which you, you know, which you
need to kill because your, you know, the acidity of your gut, again, they're one of the main
reasons why I'm against using alcohol water, the acidity of the gut, if it's above, you
know, a pH of two or 2.5, it's alkaline compared to what it should be, it should be at about
1.0 pH, it's very highly acidic and it should kill any pathogens that it comes in contact
with.
So, that's the best way to prevent parasitic infections, to have proper HCl in the gut.
Now, certainly, I, I got a bottle of our clear, pair of clear right here on my desk that I
take these, I may take four of these two times a month, just because they're good to help
kill anything that passed by HCl, time was deficient today to take something and cause
problems.
Now, the worst parasite that you could have is that we're technically a parasite, it's a bacteria,
that's Hylori, so Helicobacter Pylori is the worst overgrowth and the most common overgrowth
of bacteria, worldwide, number one cause of stomach cancer in the world, top five reasons
why you get endothelial dysfunction, aka heart disease, is Hylori, that's something that
needs to be addressed, and that's a major reason Hylori overgrowth is a major reason for
gut, epithelial damage, aka leaky gut, so dealing with that, and that's where you use HCl again
and Burberry, so that's why I'm such a big fan of Burberry because it's a cancer killer and
a H-Pylori killer, and my dad had been a heart attack at age 57, absolutely had a H-Pylori
infection.
I mean, it's ubiquitous, everybody has multiple times in their life and you just are keeping
it at bay or you're not, and it's overgrowing and it's damaging all sorts of things, and it's
another cause of cancer and more than just stomach cancer, so it's something you want to be